in einem neuen video ja eigentlich gar
nicht so fröhlich sein weil in letzter
zeit haben sich wirklich in meiner
wohnung hier komische dinge mit komisch
meine wirklich komisch und mit wirklich
komisch meine ich wirklich komische
dinge habe ich mit meinem namen mein
liebling
er hat vor einigen tagen video
hochgeladen die mir gezeigt dass in
seiner wohnung tatsächlich geister ihr
unwesen treiben überreden könnte
natürlich verhaltens über nicht mehr
verbessern müssen zeigt eine erklärung
dafür was setzen
viele haben sich wahrscheinlich gedacht
okay bei einem wenn sie das waren
menschen heute ja dort gegen den
platzierten hält er aber nein freunde
wie es mittlerweile aufgefallen seien
wirklich nicht der einzige der mit
übernatürlichen kräften mit
übernatürlichen wesen der erholung zu
kämpfen hatte ich auch es gibt fünf ort
in einer wohnung wo ich wirklich in
letzter zeit komische dinge beobachten
konnte und dem heutigen video welt
aktive fünf einfach mal zeigen ich werde
euch präsentieren das übernatürliche
kräfte wirken wenn ihr auch ein feind
von übernatürlichen kräften weiter
lassen leichter der erste ort ich euch
heute zeigen möchte die sehr kühl
schwangere nicht wirklich den
kühlschrank aufmache mit irgendwas aus
dem kühlschrank aufnehme dann fällt noch
etwas anderes ich würde sagen endet
einfach mal hier waren haben und schauen
ob wir vielleicht einen geist werden
[Musik]
oh mein gott ich würde dich die
kernstadt gerade zwei stunden wir haben
alle gesagt ich wollte nur glatten
wiederholen und wirklich die fertige app
von geisterhand rausgeflogen
als gewinn
[Musik]
minute aus
freunde seine derzeit wird alles zurück
bei mir müssen noch weiter ich habe in
dem moment halt an sippel gerufen der
gerade oben war und playstation gezockt
hat und wollte mal davon berichten was
passiert ist und er wusste wirklich gar
nicht was gerade los war
die aktuelle buch lesen
ich weiß der kamera das ist der größte
von schlafzimmer
ich werde schön gelegen und gut leben
heißt meine lieblingsbücher vasella laut
sache hier nicht irgendwelche dinge
umfallen das licht geht einfach ab und
zu aus also nicht kommen andere kamera
positioniert aber wir waren etwa
[Musik]
was
also vorhang
[Musik]
der metrobus machen
warum
dapd
[Musik]
wir haben qualitäten angeguckt werden ja
die zweite camp aufgebaut hier noch mal
eine ganz kurze slow motion wie wir den
geist gefilmt haben
das wäre wesentlich leichter ist das
viel zu sagen ich will auch gar nicht
recht ist dies eigentlich hab ich gesagt
natürlich 53 ihm werde ich habe es
bisher keine zeit habe bin ich einfach
zu krank für den heiligen geist einbruch
hatten mehrere gute platzierungen fahren
leichter
ich bin auf jeden fall aufgerollt
[Musik]